ATMs are made of two sections the bottom
is a steel safe that houses the cash
dispenser the head module contains all
the user features on top
most of the ATMs non electronic parts
are cut from steel sheets workers load
the steel sheets into a computer-guided
laser cutting machine the laser uses
focused light to generate intense heat
the heat melts the steel to make the
cuts the simpler parts are stamped with
a die in a press next a robot loads the
piece into a fully automated
computer-guided bending press the press
vens the part into the required shape
a computer-guided spot welder fuses the
simple parts together at set intervals
for more complex parts a computer-guided
3d laser welds the entire joint
an automated transport system dips the
steel parts in a metal primer to prevent
corrosion after dipping they dry the
parts in an oven the housing parts are
sprayed with liquid or powder paint then
they go into an oven to bake on the
color this is the internal structure for
the ATM's head module workers assemble
all the modules internal components
including the power unit and the ATM's
computer then they lower the head module
on to the ATM steel safe the safes walls
can be up to two inches thick there's a
separate assembly line for the operation
panel this panel goes on the front of
the head module it contains everything
used at an ATM transaction from the card
reader to the keypad and even the
speaker system the keypad encrypts the
user's personal identification number
inside the ATM the machine has up to
three security cameras they record the
keypad the cache tray and the ATM user
workers connect the monitor to the
internal computer they also install the
card reader and the receipt slot at the
bank's request they can install a
separate module for deposits however
this ATM uses the cash out slot to
accept deposits
workers also install the shutter a
computer-controlled flap on the cash out
slot it opens when the machine accepts a
deposit or dispenses money next workers
mount the operation panel to the head
module on a separate assembly line they
prepare the electronic mechanical unit
it dispenses the money and accepts cash
and checks for deposits workers load
cassettes into the unit for each cash
denomination the bank will separate and
stock the cash for their ATM before they
install the unit in the ATM they hook it
up to a test computer they test a few
different transactions with fake bills
to make sure it dispenses the correct
amount
if the unit passes testing workers
installed in the ATM safe they run a
couple of the finished machines through
several quality control tests
first a shake test ensures the ATM can
withstand a bumpy ride during transport
next they conduct a shower test to
ensure that rain won't damage an outdoor
ATM there's also a climate test they
place the ATM in a chamber that
simulates temperatures ranging from
negative 40 degrees to over 120 degrees
Fahrenheit
ATMs designed for extreme temperatures
usually have built-in heating or cooling
systems every ATM comes with basic
operating software installed the banks
that install their custom software or
have the manufacturer do it for them